de votre groupe politique voilà dans un
duel qui vous opposz à ériic kerouche un
mot sur ce qui se joue aujourd'hui vous
êtes candidat à l'élection de président
mais c'est une candidature plutôt
symbolique on est d'accord Gérard
Larchet devrait être réélu pour la 5e
fois au poste de président du Sénat
qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspireandé candidature symbolique mais
aussi une candidature de conviction je
suis un homme de gauche Gérard Larché
est un homme de droite et quel que soit
le respect qu'on porte à la personne du
président du Sénat nous nous combattons
R irement au sein du Sénat mais avec il
est vrai un enjeu qui aujourd'hui est
très très circonscrit et chacun sait que
gerér Larché sera ce soir à nouveau
président du Sénat vous disiez gauche
droite ça rappelle une époque avant 2017
on nous avait promis qu'avec l'ancien
monde ces clivages allaient être effacé
est-ce que comme on a pu lire dans la
presse c'est une revanche pour l'ancien
monde cette élection de génal arché ce
soir vous savez moi je n'ai jamais cru à
l'ancien monde et au nouveau monde j'ai
toujours cru à une forme d'aventure
individuelle qui est incarnée
aujourd'hui par Emmanuel Macron voà
qu'est-ce que sera la macronie dans 3
ans quand tout cela va se déchirer pour
la succession du président de de la
République moi je crois oui au cvage
gauche- droite c'est un élément qui
permet la respiration démocratique on
l'a vu dans la 5e République et qui
surtout je crois pour moi l'antidote à
tous les populismes donc le Sénat
incarne cela même si je regrette
l'arrivée de trois sénateurs et Ren qui
vont faire leur place je n'en doute pas
un seul instant attention danger pour
notre démoc
et quel doit être le positionnement de
l'institution face à l'exécutif on avait
vu le retentissement des commissions
d'enquête encore l'année dernière avec
celle sur le le fond Marian quelle est
l'exigence que doit porter le Sénat en
2023 ce rôle de contrôle il faudra le
continuer parce que c'est un élément de
contrepouvoir contrôle contrepouvoir
vis-à-vis d'un exécutif omnipotent et et
personnalisé de manière très direct par
le Président de la République lui-même
mais nous devons aussi être dans une
logique de proposition en tout cas pour
ce qui concerne les groupes de gauche
qui sont maintenant installés qui ont un
petit peu augmenté dans qui ont augmenté
leur place dans le Sénat combien de
poste vous pour les socialistes en plus
nous sommes à 64 nous sommes étal mais
bon vous savez la vie continue comme
dirait l'autre mais nos amis ver ont
progressé nos amis communistes ont
progressé tout ceci dans un accord
global un accord qui n'est pas un accord
de nupes mais un accord d'une gauche
peut-être plus classique mais tout aussi
efficace un mot sur votre famille
politique puisqu'on disait mardi dernier
vous avez été euh réélu président de
votre groupe politique on a vu ce matin
la réélection de Claude Rênal à la
candidature pour la présidence de la
commission des finances du Sénat mais il
va y avoir un renouvellement pour les
autres postes clés vous nous le dites à
ce micro oui nous avons euh mariearette
Carlotti qui va succéder à Jean-Pierre
Sueur euh à la questure nous avons un
des trois postes vous le savez et nous
aurons euh euh comme vice-présidente
Sylvie Robert donc sénatrice d Villen
nous avons voulu absolument au travers
de mariear Carlotti au travers de Sylvie
Robert créer la parité sur les quatre
postes principaux qui sont à la portée
du groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain et encore une dernière
question si vous me permettez mais on
l'a vu vous aviez un candidat face à
vous Éric kerouche qui est peut-être
davantage et bien proche d'Olivier fort
aussi peut-être plus favorable à ses
accords sur laanupe comment est-ce que
vous allez conserver voilà cette
homogénéité du groupe socialiste quand
on voit qu'il y a des différentes
approches sur la stratégie adopter à
gauche moi je suis socialiste je n'ai
pas changé de gremmerie permettez-moi
l'expression je suis le trop entre
guillemets comme l'on dit même si je
n'aime pas le terme de l'ensemble des
socialistes de de ce groupe et c'est je
crois que c'est ça qui est le le plus
important vous savez les congrès passe
le groupe socialiste reste très bien et
bien on verra comment et bien cette
rentrée se passe aussi pour votre
formation politique Patrick canner merci
pour cette réaction
à